je m'appelle warren marque oui je suis
du clan guerrier à pichot gardien du
visible et de l'invisible de la grande
porte du royaume de l'oci ce royaume et
celui de wayne rooney mais grands chefs
dans le sud de l'ifo la plus grande des
trois îles loyauté qui composent notre
archipel la nouvelle calédonie je suis
ce qu'on appelle ici jeunes kanaks
je fais partie du peuple autochtone dont
malang diédhiou le mot irradie signifie
littéralement en fumée vous sans fumée
il referme dans une seconde traduction
la transmission d'un monde mythique de
la voir des anciens à l'attention des
jeunes dans le monde kanak
cela s'est fait dans une case la case
est une maison de la parole elle permet
des échanges les prises de décision et
la transmission du gouvernemnt appelé
communément où traditionnellement par
les européens coutume dans la case kanak
le fait sacré en plus de réchauffer la
case il permet la solidité l'étanchéité
et la désinfection par l'enfumage autour
du feu en échange des paroles sacrées on
parle de nos connexions avec le visible
et l'invisible
ainsi le mot et avis signifie où
apparaît comme le fait de s'enfuir de
parole constructive il ya vie il ya de
graves signifiant fumée venant du feu
sacré provenant de la case nourri par
dubois dédié qui ne fait ni pleurer ni
tousser en fait ils parlent constructive
dépend de la nature du bois que l'on
utilise pour attiser le feu
mon pays est bien loin géographiquement
que culturellement de l'europe
dix-huit mille kilomètres de distance ça
fait loin 24 heures de vol deux mois de
bateaux
aujourd'hui je me pose des questions je
vis dans un quartier de new maire est
nommé à pour ceux qui ne savent pas
voilà c'est la ville principale de la
nouvelle calédonie et à nous bien je
suis confronté à des repères occidentaux
bien loin de mes repères océaniens
aujourd'hui je m'interroge sur la
société dans laquelle je vis pourquoi la
jeunesse kanake rime-t-elle avec
illettrisme addiction délinquance
suicide alors qu'ils sont les bras et
les jambes de la société kanak
pourquoi nos vieux senti le prix pour
dcni et infirme alors qu'ils étaient
sages et écouter que sont devenus mes
relations avec mes frères de la
mélanésie
alors que nous vivions depuis au moins
3500 ans dans des échanges entre les
différentes îles et archipels du
pacifique sud je m'interroge je
m'interroge sur mon existence en tant
que jeunes kanaks
où est passée ma civilisation ma société
la culture comme tout le monde j'ai
besoin de ces repères pour me dire
humain où sont passés nos valeurs
cardinales de partage de respect
d'humilité que sagesse qui sont les
fondements de nos échanges comme tout le
monde je suis connecté aux hommes
où sont passés nos liens avec le monde
végétal animal minérale cette connexion
avec le ciel et la terre
comme tout le monde je suis lié à mon
environnement auquel j'appartiens et qui
me permet de survivre
où sont passés les tertres de nos
ancêtres
comme tous les kanaks mon identité et ma
relation et mon existence des pentes
dépendent de ma relation à la terre de
mes anciens visibles et non visibles
alors à toutes ces questions
j'ai découvert quelques éléments de
réponse dans l'histoire tumultueuse de
notre pays la nouvelle calédonie de mon
pays en 17 74 avec james cook l'écossé
il le rebaptisa la terre natale de mes
ancêtres du collet de liens ou nouvelle
calédonie en français le 24 septembre
1153 lempire de france sous le règne de
napoléon iii décide de prendre
possession de la nouvelle cave ni en 10
78 une première étincelle s'allument les
kanaks de la grande-terre décide de
rallier le grand chef a taillé contre
l'occupation de ses terres et
l'oppression de l'administration
française et des collants libre la hache
de guerre est déterrée les casse-têtes
sens dans la main les sorciers en parler
une répression terrible va s'en suivre
et faire pleuvoir les larmes de nos
mères la confiance
a laissé place à la terreur et à la
colère dépouillé de sa tenue d'homme
réduira son plus simple appareil
ne pouvant plus circuler sur ses propres
terres ni parler sa propre langue
réduit au régime de l'indigénat le
peuple kanak devient étranger à lui-même
au début du 20e siècle
quelques dizaines de milliers
d'individus survivent grâce à la charité
chrétienne des européens le peuple kanak
a bien failli disparaître de la
diversité culturelle humaine
dans les années 80 sa nouvelle calédonie
est au bord d'une guerre civile et la
plupart des kanaks réclament leur
indépendance et la reconnaissance de
leur identité culturelle en 1888
puis en 1998 sans successivement 1 signé
les accords de matignon oudinot et de
nouméa qui marqueront une période de
paix jusqu'à nos jours
à partir d'un pari fait sur
l'intelligence collective donc du vivre
ensemble
mais malgré tout cela il y encore
quelques soucis
alors regardez toute cette histoire je
me demande quel bois avant nos mii dans
le foyer sacrées de notre pays quel bois
les autres en me pour pleurer et tousser
ou temps
ou sans les autres peuples de nouvelle
calédonie différents peuples sont venus
en nouvelle calédonie en plusieurs
vagues de migrations coloniale des
colons libre des aventuriers des
pionniers des religieux des
scientifiques des commerçants et aussi
les administrateurs du pays mais aussi
les collants pénaux des déportés des
bagnards des personnels des maisons et
des ouvriers travaillant sur les grands
chantiers du pays plus tard par les
kanaks
ils seront tous considérés comme
victimes de l'histoire étrangers peuples
d'ailleurs vous avez été aussi victime
du passé courage des paysans malfrats
d'un jour sur le dos au garde à vous
condamner à prendre la mer pour un
infini voyage combien d'entre vous périr
en chemin combien d'entre vous arriver à
bon port bravo l'inconnu en quête d'une
vie nouvelle partie enchaîné pour un
destin privé de liberté des hommes des
racines et au visage déboussolé qui
cherchent des repères et s'approprie des
parcelles brûlé par le soleil
sacrifiant leur sang au nom d'un empire
colonial devenu trop lointain sur une
terre rouge voyante les bagnards venus
de la france métropolitaine se brûle les
mains
que reste-t-il des vous peuple expatriés
aujourd'hui je constate que nous
connaissons bien peu l'histoire des
autres
finalement que connaissant pas du tout
pourtant cette histoire des kanaks m'a
enseigné que nous avions bien besoin de
nous parler de nous rencontrer
on parle ici de destin commun mais il
est encore loin devant nous et il a
beaucoup de chemin à faire surtout dans
le coeur de chacun ce pays est métissé
par son histoire mais peu par sa culture
sans volonté de partager une identité
commune et assumé il est difficile
d'obtenir un vivre ensemble quel bois
d'âge m quel bois émis par les autres
quel bois de volants de nous mettre
ensemble on nous enfume et des paroles
constructive qui ne fait ni pleurer ni
tousser
avec les accords de paix nous sommes
condamnés à vivre ensemble et non plus à
survivre chacun de notre côté
grâce à ce que j'ai appris du passé
j'aimerais mettre du bois dédié à la
parole qui construit qui permettent à
mon peuple de vivre et d'être acceptée
en retour construire un pays nécessite
de l'intelligence collective que chacun
chaque peuple met un bois dédié qui ne
fait ni pleurer nitoo c'est un bois qui
prouve qu'ils profitent à tous qu'ils
aillent dans le sens de l'intérêt
général et qui permette à chacun ou
chacune d'entre nous de s'épanouir
je me demande s'il ne serait pas
possible d'allier par exemple la pensée
occidentale et les pensées océaniennes
est une chimère et seulement il réaliste
et réalisable seulement une promesse
pourquoi ne pas enrichir chacune dépensé
dans des éléments de culture de l'autre
pourquoi pas enlever le cas denis
il a eu beaucoup de conflits syndicaux
et pour régler ses conflits il a été mis
en place un dialogue social c'est à dire
des techniques de communication
consensuelle et plus précisément entre
le salariat est le patronat dans le
secteur privé
c'est à dire qu'on essayait de voir la
conception occidentale de l'entreprise
et les façons de faire
où les pratiques océaniennes du travail
grâce à ce dialogue social le management
l'organisation les façons de travailler
sont beaucoup plus cohérente avec la
réalité de la société calédonienne les
identités personnelles et collectives
des océaniens plus particulièrement des
kanak sont valorisés et la confiance
elle est revenu fort de cette expérience
j'imagine que nous pourrions aller plus
loin aller plus loin en systématisant la
bisexualité bicéphale en océanie ne
signifie pas séparés opposé meslier est
différent ce qui induit un
enrichissement réciproque le secteur
public reste encore aujourd'hui liées
aux pratiques occidentales
pourquoi ne pas imaginer des documents
administratifs
traduit du français en langue
océaniennes puisque les langues kanak et
polynésiennes sont enseignés jusqu'à
l'université
donc du coup la barrière de la langue
les incompréhensions la peur de ne pas
savoir se relever et le secteur public
calédonien serait beaucoup plus proche
de ses concitoyens aussi anja paerson ne
pleurerait vous ne toucherez aujourd'hui
nous devrions être tous capables de
marcher les uns vers les autres
nous pourrions touche mettre du bois
dans le foyer sacrées de notre grande
case qui ne fait ni pleurer ni tous et
c'est à nous de voir la différence que
nous voulons faire
maintenant c'est nous je vous remercie